My stomach still sticks out and I can't figure out why. Well, I can figure out why my
mind sticks out, but that's what it looks like. I've had a good weight, eat clean, take
all my supplements, and many have to do with detoxification. I'm asking not because
of vanity, but because I wonder if I'm missing a step of detoxification or something else.
I know that my gut health is so important. Well, dealing with cancer, someone suggested
I should, I could be, it could be related to cortisol. I've received Dr. Rick Holos
Neuroarticle about adding carbs back to the diet once you've resolved insulin resistance,
something he never thought he'd say. Okay, so I need more information than my stomach sticks
out. You know, are you bloated? Is it inflammation? Is there a sideys present? Is it always
or is it only after a meal? Is it, you know, there's lots of questions that need to be asked
with this question that can lead to different things. Certainly, it's not that you're just
missing a supplement. So, some major causes in abdominal bloating can be, you know, hidden
H. Pylori infections, dysbiosis, which, you know, so when you're dealing with digestion,
you have to start from the top down. You know, this is person I've adequate H.C.L. production
so that they're digesting proteins and carbs in their stomach in the first part of the
swallow test and call the duodenum. Do they have number two good production of pancreatic
enzymes and health in the pancreas that's released? Number three, does this person have issues
with their gallbladder, the major cause of bloating right there? Because if you have issues with
your gallbladder, that's what I call phase four of the detoxification process, then you're
going to have issues. So, that could be an issue. How do you know if you have gallbladder
issues? Well, the best way to know is to get an ultrasound with a gallbladder to see if you
have sludge or stilds in the gallbladder. But how else could you get hints that you have
gallbladder issues? Do you have issues eating when you eat fatty foods? Does it give you
a little tummy ache? Some people aren't sensitive enough to know that. Some people just kind
of inherently, well, I don't eat a lot of fatty foods. Well, why? Because it bothers me.
So, well, there you go. That's why a hint that you have gallbladder issues. So gallbladder
issues are very close, even more common with females over 40, that could cause that bloating
issue. Those things all can lead to damage, gut epithelial layers, and gut permeability issues,
NKA leaking gut issues, intestinal dysbiosis that can happen regardless of whether the person
has cancer. It can be completely separate from a person's cancer diagnosis, some comorbidity,
not really completely related to anything else going on with the cancer. So, very common
issues that I just talked about right there. So, how would you know that? How would you
dress that? There are certainly labs that you could run to deal with those kind of things.
But you started with, I think I have a blog post about HCL and H. Kylo right? That would
be helpful to look at that first and follow some of those steps.
As far as adding carbs back to your diet, let's you resolve the insulin resistance issue.
I'm totally, I do believe that we're not supposed to be carb-free in our diet, but we're
dealing with cancer. All that kind of stuff goes out the window. We're trying not to fuel
the cancer and things, so you have to get back to our previous questions that we talked
about that. So, it's not just about insulin resistance and we're talking about what I'm
trying to fuel the cancer.